what do you think my derivative yes no
maybe I think it looks okay do you see
what I've done I couldn't avoid the
question rule so I just I just went
straight for it
by the time I got to here I saw okay
I've collected like terms I want to
factor eyes theme but I just don't trust
myself with negative signs so I pulled
the negative signs out by factorizing
like this and this guy here is a monic
quadratic which I've been doing since
forever
so I'm reasonably happy with that okay
now what was the point of
differentiating what was the use of
finding a derivative I'm looking for
stationary points so I've got two
stationary points right here okay if
this is the derivative then stationary
points are going to exist at x equals
what and what negative 3 or 1 now just
like before you can see that the domain
that's been provided to us makes one of
these irrelevant okay so I'm just gonna
ignore this guy right here at this point
I know I have a stationary point okay
and now it's probably helpful if I get
an idea of like what does this picture
look like okay
I want to test some points yeah now I've
got an endpoint here x equals 0 to test
I've got an endpoint here right because
I'm I'm ignoring this one so it's just
this one which I'm interested in so I'll
test those is there another value I
ought to test
are there any other stationary points in
the domain and so no is there another
endpoint that I need to test answer no
this like it keeps going and if there's
no number you could pick you like Oh a
million I'm finished no you're not
finished million in 1 right so there's
no final value which makes this a bit
weird that's the reason why I've picked
up this example so all I need to do is
let's just Chuck these numbers in to see
what happens okay because I've just got
one endpoint at one stationary point
this is gonna be a pretty quick thing to
fill out I've got an x value and I've
got a y value before I do this Eric did
you have a hand up for a question or
okay we'll see let's see how we go maybe
in order I guess we go 0 the endpoint
and then 1 the stationary points always
put the zoom
in point the stationary point so when x
equals zero what do you get a third when
x equals one
looks like you're getting two over four
which is a half okay question yep
which I was just getting to let's start
to piece this thing together ah very
good question and I will ask that
question as we start to piece together
water Malthus he looks like okay so as
Eric pointed out we do have a horizontal
acetate how do we know that how do we
know yeah this is a nominator has a
bigger power it's going to take over
whatever is got the biggest power is
always with the driver's seat okay so
you're going to get this y equals zero a
subdue it miles well labeled there okay
here's an interesting one if we were to
graph regions on this don't do it just
think about it if we were to graph
region on this what would they look like
remember I'm only thinking about this
domain tell me what this looks like the
numerator in this domain it's just going
to be just this line it sort of starts
here it just goes up right so tell me
about the sine of that factor it's
always positive right all right this guy
in fact for all values of X this guy is
always products so if I didn't want to
shade regions the regions would look
like this it's just gonna stay up here
it's a bit boring that's why I didn't
bother too much to make you do it okay
so now I've got an endpoint let's call
that a third is a half bubble below
above so that already tells you that
this is a maximum right it's a
stationary point at least that's what I
expect to happen okay because you can
see I've got to come back down you've
got that horizontal asymptote to come
back to so it's gonna look some ideas do
you agree where else can we go right
it's not going to skyrocket off because
we're really identified the asymptotes
so I'm done now I'm looking for a
maximum that's an
to answer where's the maximum the
maximum occurs at x equals one but the
heart of the actual maximum itself is
and a half okay so that's easy to answer
the maximum is a huh now then you get to
this other question in the minimum so
the minimum sort of implies just like if
you've got a point of inflection in
actual point that it goes to the minimum
implies there's a specific value I can
see here right now what do you think
would be the best candidate for an
answer for the minimum of this function
so there's a third
it's definitely lower than a half but I
could go lower than this kind I I'm
going towards this horizontal asymptote
so I'm gonna get lower than a third I go
to 1/4 or 1/5
can I get lower than that it's a yes I
can't get lower in fact I can get as low
as I like except there's a point I have
to stop there's a point I can never get
to what's the point zero you can never
get to zero right so what that means is
there's no value you can say like you
can't say it's on 0.0001 because you can
go lower than that right you can't say
zero point zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero one because you can still go lower
than that but you can't say zero I
thought because you can't get there
right so we're kind of in a jam what we
have to conclude is the maximum is 1/2
and there is no minimum because there's
no value you could say that you can get
there and no further but once you get to
zero you can't actually get this so it
can't be called the minimum because you
never arrived okay
was that one of the questions you're
sort of getting out or or a different
question
all right so this is one of those tricky
things where we have to be so careful
with limits right limits are a very
convenient option like we've talked
about this guy right and we've said da
da da da da for all intents and purposes
we can say that thing is one right we
can say it is one but it's only because
we choose to say yes I'll agree to let
the limit be that definition but here
can you see like it doesn't make sense
to call it the minute because you never
get there so it never actually takes on
that value so that's why weirdly this
has no minimum yeah correct if I had the
other side of this graph I could say
there was a relative minima because
there's another stationary point down
here when you got x equals negative 3
you'll get a relative minimum in fact in
that case it will be the absolute min
because it can be negative
from what I remember you can graph it
you can find out ok but you can't say
there's a relative minimum here either
because the early stationary of what you
have is a maximum right once you
determine the nature which you can see
for the ground
no no so if I kept going like that would
be the minimum it's not a stationary
point just like this is the maximum it's
not a stationary point but it depends on
how your domain has been restricted okay
because you can get lower than a third
yes that's true
relative only really makes sense when
you're talking about stationary points
right so it doesn't yeah like the
language of relative minimum only is
only applied to stationary points
because we're forced into that you can't
say it's V maximum it's only that
maximum relative relative to what's
around it